hey what's up guys how you doing how's
it going so it's been like a week since
i last uploaded a video why so long a
lot of people are asking well at a
fairly good reason i was actually kind
of in shock and awe that this happened
but i'm back now of course and better
than ever before you could say i've got
a little something for a lucky one of
you remember this guy the samsung galaxy
s3 if you don't i did a review on it so
it's like right here but yeah we're
giving one of these away i say we
because i'm working with samsung one of
you commenters will win a galaxy s3
directly from samsung for your carrier
so all you have to do is include the
name of your carrier that carries the
galaxy s3 in your comment below and bam
you are entered to win and of course
leaving a thumbs up on the video because
you probably like a giveaway video and
subscribing if you haven't already to
stay tuned to the more current videos
that are going to be coming out are
highly encouraged as well so you have
one week to leave your single comment
that includes your carrier of choice and
whatever other text you want to include
in your comment and from those i'll be
picking one random winner so if you have
any other questions all the other
information will be down in the
description below this video and lastly
i just want to thank every single one of
you guys that i possibly can who has
watched and enjoyed my videos
thumbs up on my videos subscribe to my
channel uh showed a video to one of your
friends shared a video of mine on
twitter on facebook on google plus
myspace
thank you so i'll see you guys in the
next video good luck
peace
you